(man) the sharks are back
in an all-New season
of "Shark tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I'm buying you now
for an obscene amount of money.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You gotta crawl
before you ball.
This doesn't make any sense.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
What were your sales
for the year?
$12,000.
Ohh!
Whoa!
Things Got very chilly
in here.
It's sink...
if you don't take my offer,
Nicole, the bear dies.
Or swim.
(Lori) This is what I always do.
Shark fight! Shark fight!
(cheering and laughter)
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
First up are Dave Petrillo
and Dave Jackson
with an innovation
aimed at coffee lovers.
♪♪♪
Hey, sharks.
I'm Dave Jackson.
And I'm Dave Petrillo.
We invented coffee joulies.
And I'm confident that
before we leave here today,
one or more of you is going
to invest $150,000
in exchange for a 5%
equity stake in our company.
(laughs)
Coffee is never
the right temperature.
It's served around
180 degrees fahrenheit.
If I were gonna pour
a glass of this for myself
and take a sip,
I'd burn my tongue
and not be able
to taste anything
for the rest of the day.
So what do I need to do?
I'm gonna wait around
for it to cool,
and finally, eventually,
it'll be perfect
for, like, that much time.
Before I know it,
it's too cold
and I'm pouring it
down the drain.
Coffee joulies solves
both of these problems.
First...
(clatters)
They absorb extra heat
from your coffee
and make it a drinkable
temperature within minutes.
And then they release
the heat that they stored
and keep it in
the perfect drinking range
for up to twice as long.
Wow.
Our favorite way to use
coffee joulies
is in this vacuum-Insulated
travel mug.
(sloshing)
in here, you can pour in
coffee as hot as you want,
and it'll be the perfect
drinking temperature
in five minutes,
and it'll stay that way
for over five hours.
We have five perfection packs
here for you to try out
with coffee that we poured
over three hours ago.
What is the right temperature
to drink coffee at?
The right temperature is
140 degrees fahrenheit.
It will not burn your tongue.
It's a pleasant temperature,
and it gives you good flavor
and aroma for your coffee.
Thermoses already
keep things hot.
But they keep them too hot,
especially right when you pour
your coffee into the thermos--
It'll be too hot
for a long period of time.
Holy smokes.
Lori, look at this.
Right.
Three hours ago.
Three hours old?
Yep.
How does it monitor
the temperature
when it gets in,
and it retains the heat
and monitors how much
it has to give off?
There's material
inside the joulies
that melts
at 140 degrees fahrenheit.
So you put it in hot coffee--
Coffee that's poured at 180--
It absorbs all that
extra energy,
cooling it down to 140.
When it hits 140,
the process reverses,
releasing the energy
back into the coffee,
keeping it hot longer.
Are you a chemist?
That's fascinating.
We're both
mechanical engineers.
We're both--Yeah.
Oh. What is this made out of?
Is this stainless steel?
The outside
is 18/10 stainless steel,
and the inside is a proprietary
phase Change material that's--
Did you come up with it?
Uh...
we did not.
There's a company
that makes it,
and we like that,
because they've done
the effort of making sure
it's safe.
So, Dave,
what's the response been?
Wait, wait. Let him finish.
Let him finish up, Kevin.
It's all derived
from plant sources,
so it's edible.
You can actually eat this stuff.
So what is it that--
That's inside?
As soon as you sign your n.D.A.,
we can talk about that.
(laughter)
We have a design patent
that's been issued,
and we have a utility patent
that's pending,
and we have, uh, trademarks
in the United States
and in China.
Does this work with tea
as well?
Yes.
Yeah. It works with
any hot beverage.
Tea, hot chocolate. Someone
put them in oatmeal, we heard.
People use them in soup.
And you only need one
in a--in a mug?
One per 4 ounces of coffee
is our guideline.
(Lori) One for 4 ounces.
Oh!
Yeah.
So I'm, like, plopping
multiple of these.
Multiple of them in. There's
five in your coffee right now.
That's a 16-Ounce
travel mug, and--
There's five in here?
Wow.
Yeah, there's five
in there.
So you have to walk around
like you got a pack
of marlboros on you.
I drink three, four cups
a day. I love coffee,
but I don't carry a mug
with me.
I can't see me carrying
jewels around.
Joulies.
(mark and Lori) Joulies.
Joulies. Sorry. So who's
the target market?
In our past sales,
we've had the most traction
as a gift item.
Because everyone
drinks coffee,
and these are terrific
to give someone
who's a-a real
coffee enthusiast.
How much does one cost to make?
One joulie to make
costs $3.65,
including all the testing.
And you're selling them
for how much?
$50--
$50 for a set of 5.
What were your sales
for the year?
$575,000 last year.
Five--Yeah.
Wow.
What did you profit
on the $575,000?
Last year our profit
on the books was like $50,000.
We spent a lot of money
on patents, tooling, legal fees.
And you expensed
all of that?
Yeah.
We're--We're
cash flow positive.
Dave, what are you
gonna sell this year?
Over a million dollars.
Last year was the year
of online sales for us.
But our focus this year
is gonna be going
into wholesale accounts.
We have 2 different retailers
with 1,000 stores each
that want to carry
our product.
Which ones?
Bed bath & beyond, officemax.
So, um, Dave and Dave,
you've been gracious enough
to offer us 5%.
(laughs)
so you're valuing the company
at $3 million.
That's right.
(Kevin) Are you gonna
address his question?
No, no, no.
They don't need to address me.
Is there a question there?
They don't need to address me,
'cause I think you guys
are about to do some
really invasive surgery on them
about that 5%. Um...
I'm out.
We're so far apart,
in my view.
When--When I fund startups,
I want a minimum of 33%.
I don't know how
to value you right now.
I'll give you $150,000,
and what I want
is $6 from every order
till I get it back, okay?
And then $1 in Perpetuity
after that.
I'll go in
on the deal with you,
if you would like a partner.
Can you put some power
behind it on qvc?
I think so.
I think we can.
I welcome you in, Lori.
Kevin, I can help you
with the bed bath & beyond.
I mean, daymond and I
do deal with them.
I think I can get that
faster into retail
and some of the other retailers,
like target.
You've got three sharks
now under that structure.
You keep the company.
There's one--One person
we haven't heard--
(mark) But wait. There's more.
We haven't heard from yet.
But wait. There's more.
First of all, I think
you're crazy to go retail
and wholesale.
Okay.
Absolutely loony bin nuts.
Because your costs
go through the roof.
Okay.
I'd like to get involved,
but I don't know want to be
in the wholesale distribution
business,
because you lose control
of your own destiny,
particularly this early.
Right?
You gotta crawl
before you ball. Right?
And the minute it goes
to bed bath & beyond,
they control who you are.
(Lori) This doesn't make
any sense.
I've done over $500 million
in retail sales,
and the reason?
Because I do exactly
the opposite
of what mark just said.
You get it out as wide
and as fast
into everybody that you can.
You have the whole world
Knowing what joulies is fast.
If you go with the way
mark was saying,
you could crawl along
like a snail forever.
You know what?
If They would allow me,
I'll come in on this, too,
to do the retail,
'cause I believe in it.
And when Lori puts it on,
then you can do "As seen on tv"
in the stores.
Are you gonna let him back in?
He seemed--
I don't know,
earlier he was kinda...
(Lori laughs)
Yeah, he was a little--He was
a little poopy, wasn't he?
The truth about this guy is,
he is Mr. Retail.
And even though sometimes
I don't like him,
I like to make money.
So enemies become friends
When they can help you.
Kevin, let's bring daymond in.
We need daymond on this.
(Lori) I would bring daymond in
for sure.
I'm happy to have him in.
(Kevin) Here's the offer.
Very simple.
You get $150,000
from 4 sharks.
Every time you sell a unit,
give us $6 back.
Any unit?
Any unit.
Even wholesale, where
our margins today are--
Any unit, $6 back.
You'll get focused on this,
because as soon as we get
our money back,
it drops to a dollar.
That's it. And you keep
100% of the company
for when that big coffee company
Comes and says,
"I'm buying you now
for an obscene amount of money,"
so you can buy suits.
(mark) right.
So just think about that.
First of all, you'd be
an idiot if you bought a suit.
But--
Do you have to think
about that?
Is there an offer that
you'd like to make?
(mark) Sure.
I'd like to make an offer.
Let's hear it.
Okay. I'm gonna offer you
$250,000
for 12%, no royalties.
My preference is that
you don't go
wholesale/retail
and qvc right away,
because I see this as having
a great opportunity
for a liquidity event.
I see this as being able
to sell the company.
When you go to sell the company
and they say,
"Let's look at your numbers,"
first Big old red flag
is going to be
a perpetual royalty.
Doesn't matter
if it's a penny.
It's not gonna be negotiated
out on a buyout
as simply as it sounds.
Absolutely will.
Happens every day.
Can I finish?
When you have a company
that is looking to grow,
you can't be on qvc
every week all the time.
Tell that to George Foreman,
who did about $400 million
over five years.
And he has to go back
to that environment
and to--
No, he doesn't.
He's in retail.
It's in every single store
all over the country.
It's one of the largest
retail stores--
It was one of the largest
Retail products ever. Ever.
He gave--He gave you--
he gave you his offer.
Can we call our friend?
Yeah. We're gonna--
We're gonna call
an adviser that we have.
Go ahead.
Well, there's
a difference in the offers
and there's a difference
in the strategy.
Yeah.
And they're very--
and there's a difference
in the experience
of the people that are giving
you this advice and offers.
They're all very different.
Good luck to you.
All right.
We'll be right back.
I say we go up to $9.
(chuckles)
I think we're in trouble
on the, uh,
wholesale amount, Kevin.
Why? It can support 6 bucks.
(daymond) No, it can't.
His manufacturing Cost
is too high right now.
I-I saw his look
on the wholesaling.
Yeah. I think wholesale--
I gotta tell you, I think--
Wholesale you can have--
I think if we don't
change that offer,
we're gonna lose this deal.
♪♪♪
His manufacturing Cost
is too high right now.
I-I saw his look
on the wholesaling.
Yeah. I think wholesale--
I gotta tell you, I think--
Wholesale you can have--
I think if we don't
change that offer,
we're gonna lose this deal.
(man) How are you guys?
We're doing very well here.
We have two offers.
Uh, one is from mark.
He was looking for
a 12% stake for $250,000.
So we're gonna lose him
on that.
(Lori) right. Right.
I saw the look on his eye
when we--
right. It is True.
When he asked wholesale.
It is True. It is True.
Gentlemen?
Gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen.
We're gonna change and modify
our offer a little bit,
'cause we really wanna do it.
Okay.
We're gonna drop--
On wholesale, it's only $3.
Okay.
And on retail, it's $6.
Because we don't want to
burden you too much
on the wholesale product.
Okay.
Do you understand
what I'm saying?
Yes.
And then that drops to a dollar
afterwards in perpetuity.
Okay.
Got it?
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right, so the new offer
that Kevin just
walked up to us to give
was $1 in perpetuity
royalty
on any product we sell...
did--What did you say?
I modified the offer.
What did you go down to?
I went to $3 and $6.
I like it. Makes sense.
This is a $150,000 investment
and a $3 royalty
on Wholesale packs
until that's paid back.
Where are you leaning
at the moment?
They're talking a long time.
They are talking
a long time.
Usually not a good sign.
All right, well, I think we're--
Our mind is made up here.
Thanks a lot for your time.
Yeah, of course.
Thanks, Tim.
Keep it up.
Good luck to you guys.
All right. I'll talk to you
soon. All right. Bye.
Okay, Bye.
♪♪♪
Sorry to keep you guys
waiting.
(Kevin) hold on. Let's just
summarize the offers here, okay?
Okay.
Um, from four sharks,
you've got an offer
for exactly what you asked for--
$150,000.
We're going to ask for $6
from every retail order
and $3 from every
Wholesale order until
the $150,000's been recouped.
And after that,
we get a dollar
from every order
in perpetuity.
You get 100% of the company.
We do not put covenants on you
on how you run it.
(laughs)
now there's another offer
from Mr. Cuban.
He's also a shark.
Standard deal.
12% for $250,000,
but all kinds of covenants
in his own vision about
how to run a coffee company.
No covenants, right?
Just a difference in strategy
and approach.
This is the beginning
of a new journey for you
one way or the other.
It's remarkable.
You've created something
out of nothing.
It has tremendous potential.
We all see that.
Now it's time to make
a decision.
What are you going to do?
♪♪♪
Mark, thank you
for making the offer,
but we're gonna
have to go with
the four sharks
and their offer.
Whoa.
Yeah, baby!
Ah!
Good job, guys.
Juan Valdez.
Good job, Dave.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, great job.
Great product.
Congratulations.
Thanks a lot. I'm excited.
This is gonna be fun.
Nice meeting you.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Thanks a lot.
Oh, man.
Wow, all the sharks were in.
Oh, there was one missing.
Oh.
(Lori laughs)
You guys were just as shocked
as I am.
(laughing)
Mark, you know in the shark tank
sometimes you win
and sometimes you lose.
No, not me.
I think you just lost.
Wow. I love his confidence
even when he's defeated.
He's weeping inside.
Trust me.
We came to "Shark tank,"
got exactly what we wanted.
And we didn't even give up
any of our equity.
It was amazing.
It's perfect.
♪♪♪
In season 3, Rachael Mann
and Mackenzie Burdick
made a deal with daymond John
and mark Cuban
for their unique
jewelry brand litter.
Yes.
Thank you.
(mark laughs)
Let's see what they're
up to now.
Making a deal with the sharks
is the best thing we could
have done for our business.
The doors that have opened up
for us are priceless.
We are here in l.A. Today
because daymond
has set us up with
Frederick's of hollywood.
Daymond recently closed
a deal for us
to design special pieces
just for Frederick's.
We are so excited
to see what you brought.
Rachael and I came up
with a bra kit
that we think would
look wonderful.
Before the "Shark tank,"
our lifetime sales
were $90,000,
and after the show aired,
we made that in a few days.
And we're looking at $3 million
in sales just this year.
$3 million.
When daymond first brought
your brand to me,
I was really excited about
what you all were doing.
You guys did
such an outstanding job.
You so understand our girl.
The meeting went great.
We had such a good time.
They loved the pieces.
It could not have been better.
Hello?
Hi, daymond.
It's Rachael and Mackenzie.
Hey!
Hey, guys!
We're so excited.
It was such a great meeting.
Mark Cuban and daymond John Have
been amazing mentors for us.
Congratulations. I think
it's a great first step,
and I can't wait
to tell mark.
The whole "Shark tank"
Experience has been amazing.
It's been a bumpy road
getting to this point,
and we just couldn't be
more grateful.
♪♪♪
I'm Nicole townend, and I'm from
Huntington beach, california.
Yeah, dad!
Yeah!
I'm married to professional
skateboarder tosh townend,
and we have a 2-year-Old
daughter named jemmaly.
Stop it!
Having a 2-year-Old daughter
is so messy.
She's constantly picking up
things,
putting them in her mouth,
dragging things in the house
from outside.
It's a constant battle keeping
things clean and germ-Free.
Jemmaly, he's dirty.
He needs his own bath.
I found it hard to keep
everything
safe and clean for my daughter.
Surprisingly, I found that
there was nothing on the market
to fix this problem.
Due to the slowing economy,
tosh hasn't been getting
as much money for skateboarding.
I had to start
raising money on my own
with a business that nobody
had ever heard of before.
If I don't get an investment
from the sharks,
I could lose my business,
my house.
My family is depending
on the success of this company.
So I have a lot on the line.
♪♪♪
Hello. I'm Nicole townend,
creator of Teddy needs a bath.
I'm seeking $50,000 in exchange
for 10% of my business.
Teddy needs a bath
is the first
Washer and Dryer bag
for stuffed animals.
We've all seen the kid
who's been dragging his Teddy
around the mall floor
all day,
and we know it's gonna
end up in his bed that night,
or even worse,
in his mouth.
(chuckles)
How gross is that?
Teddy needs a bath
comes to the rescue,
making it easy for parents
to safely clean
their child's
favorite friend
while knowing it's not gonna
get destroyed in the process.
The best part about
Teddy needs a bath
is that it's so easy
to use.
Simply throw a dozen
small toys inside...
(zipper unzips)
(clicks)
Or...
one large dirty Teddy.
Bad Teddy.
(laughter)
Then you zip up the big,
chunky, kid-Friendly zipper.
How can he breathe in there?
It's porous.
(laughter)
You throw it
in the Washer alone
or with a load
of your laundry on gentle.
Then it goes straight
into the Dryer on low.
When that's done...
you have a fresh, fluffy,
germ-Free toy
to go back into the arms
of your loved one.
(laughs)
I also have some
samples of the bag
to give to you guys,
and the children's book that
I created to go along with it.
Thank you.
Nicole, obvious question--
Why can't I just
throw the Teddy in there?
Oh, it scratches
the plastic eyes,
the seams can get busted out,
and it can also cause
a lot of damage
to your Washer and Dryer.
We're trying to build
awareness
to the importance of removing
germs and allergens
from stuffed animals.
There's something I never
thought of, actually,
to tell you the truth, about
how dirty the Teddy may be.
A lot of parents,
they don't think
it's something
that you need to do.
There are bags out there
like that already
for cleaning
other types of laundry.
But they're all mesh.
I have seen ones
that are cotton.
What is to stop, like, anybody
from just making
this kind of thing?
Well, it's patent pending.
There was no bag
with a zipper?
There's no laundry bag
that's geared towards
WASHING stuffed animals.
So tell us what it costs
to make one
and how you've been
doing at it.
Okay.
So it costs me $2.25
to get it made overseas,
and I retail for $14.99.
We did our hard launch
in January,
when we were featured
on the "today" Show.
We've been on babies"R"Us'
web site for four months,
and we've sold
a couple hundred units,
but this is solely based
on word of mouth.
So, Nicole, what period of time
did you just cover?
Six months?
Six months.
And what were your total sales
in that six months?
$12,000.
Have you shown it to any
of the baby big box players,
the buyers?
Yes, we're--So babies"R"Us
is very happy with us,
and they've asked us
to come to New York.
So you think you're going to get
into all babies"R"Us's, right?
Yes. Mm-hmm.
Did they tell you that?
Was that an assurance,
or was it just...
"We really like your sales
online.
"We'd like you to come out
and discuss
testing it
in our brick-and-Mortar."
I really want
to tell you guys,
the cool thing about
the Dryer sheets is that,
first of all, there's no
Dryer sheets that I'm aware of
that have fun, funky smells.
So this one smells exactly
like cotton Candy.
Now I like that.
(mark) Yeah,
I like that, too.
(laughs) Yeah.
If you guys wanna smell it,
it's really fun.
Bring it on.
And it's all natural
ingredients,
because we want to sell to
the whole foods and the mothers.
Smells really Good. (laughs)
I think that's
a bigger business.
That smelled like cotton Candy.
My kids would love it.
I think you have a home run
there with the--
With the way
that Teddy smells.
Yeah, I think so, too.
I see there's a need.
I'm just wondering
how big a need,
how much this would catch on.
You don't really know yet.
You're at the beginnings.
And I have seen bags like this.
So for that reason, I'm out.
With our three kids,
it's the biggest pain...
right.
Trying to figure out
what's causing the allergies,
the eczema.
Right.
And you go down a checklist
trying to remove everything.
But, mark, somebody's washing
your Teddy bears, for sure.
I do all the washing
at our house.
No way!
Oh, whatever!
When was the last time you did
a load of laundry, Robert?
Anyway...
I did my own
a couple days ago.
(laughs)
Are moms gonna go out
and spend $14 for really...
in a heartbeat.
We have interest,
and rite aid, walgreens,
cvs, and target have all asked
for samples, and have them.
It's interesting, but I just
can't see women buying it
and you growing
a market out of it.
I don't see it. I'm out.
Big valuation, I think,
is a little too early.
You need to be
a little more proven
for me to be able
to help you.
So I'm out.
I'll tell you a little story
which is really moving me.
I'm very moved,
because when I was a child...
(daymond) aw.
I was allergic to house dust.
I used to--
Every week I'd have to go
get an injection.
And I had no idea
Teddy was killing me.
Seriously.
I wouldn't have hung out
with Teddy so much.
It's serious.
That's why I really have
a connection with what
you're trying to do.
I see that. (chuckles)
are you one of those
30% of men
who travel
with their Teddy bears?
Yes!
No!
(laughter)
You are not worth
half a million dollars.
I'm sorry.
I'll give you the $50,000
for 50% of the business.
But I have to have
10% of sales...
(laughs) Kevin.
(Kevin) Paid to me
every month.
Because I'll never get
my cash back.
And after I get my cash back,
I'll drop that to 5%.
Okay.
(mark) Have you done
any independent testing
to get, like--Here's exactly
what the benefits are
compared to a pillowcase
or anything else?
Oh, yes.
So I teamed up
with this manufacturer
of Washer and dryers--
Frigidaire and electrolux.
Okay.
They supplied
an antimicrobial
test laboratory.
The only offer I'm aware of
right now, Nicole, is mine.
Nicole, I'll make it easier.
You've convinced me
that it serves a need.
Okay.
So I want to make you
an offer.
But is $50,000 enough?
If you're gonna have
all these purchase order--
Yeah, I'm gonna need an investor
that I can come back to again
for the purchase orders.
Here's what I'm willing
to offer.
Because you're gonna need
more capital...
Mm-hmm.
And the better you do, obviously
the more capital you need,
because you want to be able
to hit those $10,000,
$20,000, $50,000
minimum orders...
right.
I'm willing to invest
$100,000...
but I want 40% of the company.
I'll drop the equity ask
from 50% down to 30%,
'cause he's being too greedy.
So my offer now is,
I will give you the $50,000
for 30% of the company...
and I want a 10% royalty
on sales to get my cash back.
But when it gets returned,
it drops to 5%.
And if you need more cash,
call Mr. Wonderful.
He's always there.
Do the math, Nicole.
Can I speak with my husband
about your 40%?
Yes. Feel free.
Okay. I'll be right back.
♪♪♪
I have two offers.
You guys are giving her
such a high valuation
on this company.
Ridiculous.
(mark) It's not
a high valuation.
Cuban went crazy.
One order. One order and you
get all your money back.
I think, with your gut instinct,
you'll do good.
All right. Thank you, baby.
All right?
Love you.
Okay. Thank you.
Love you, too.
High-Five.
Get 'em.
♪♪♪
Nicole, welcome back.
Hi. Thank you.
So, Nicole,
you've got two offers here.
Right.
But before you speak,
another piece of information
you need to know--
No, no "before you speaks."
No, this is important, mark.
You don't take my offer, Nicole,
the bear dies.
(laughter)
Okay, I have to say, Kevin,
I'm blown away
by your intrigue in this.
The only problem I have with
that is the royalty's forever.
I'll tell you what.
I'll drop
the royalty
that's there forever.
I'll just keep the 10% there
till I get my money back.
Okay, let me ask this
to mark first.
I have a counteroffer
for you.
Okay.
$100,000 for 30%,
but with a 10% royalty
until you get your money back.
Done, done, and done.
Whoo!
Bear dies.
Oh!
(laughter)
Thank you. Oh, wow.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Thank you.
It's gonna be great.
Good job, Nicole.
Thank you.
(Lori) Congratulations.
Good luck.
It was so nice
to meet all of you.
(mark) Thank you.
Whew!
The product is great,
the design is great.
She's done a phenomenal job.
I don't care.
The bear still dies.
(laughs)
I saw it.
I got a deal
with the sharks!
We got it! We got it! Yay!
No way! Yes!
Can you believe it?
Oh, my gosh.
Ooh!
Big, happy family.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
are Jerry and Naomi Hancock
with an innovation
to a beloved treat.
Sharks,
we're Naomi and Jerry Hancock,
and our family business
is sub zero ice cream,
and today we're gonna
blow you away.
We're asking for $300,000...
(sighs)
(whooshing)
(Lori) Whoo!
(sharks laughing)
Whoo!
You couldn't remember that
on your own?
You had to be reminded?
(laughing)
How do you forget that?
Exactly. You're right.
We're asking you for $300,000
for 12% of our business.
Welcome
to sub zero ice cream.
We've developed a method
of making
frozen desserts
right in front of the customer
using liquid nitrogen.
Cool.
So how do we do it?
Well, let's show you.
Today, Jerry is gonna
make me some ice cream.
Imagine an ice cream store
without a single freezer,
for the possibilities
are endless.
And you have fresh, frozen,
custom ice cream
made to order from start
to finish within one minute...
(whooshing)
Oh, cool!
From order to delivery.
Wow.
Within seconds,
your ice cream goes
from liquid to frozen.
We never get tired
of seeing people's reaction
as they see
their ice cream freeze
right in front of their eyes.
(scraping)
Kids love it.
They go crazy over it.
In fact, once they've seen
sub zero,
they don't want to go
anywhere else.
So we have some samples
for you to try.
Sharks, enjoy your ice cream.
Take your time.
If it starts to melt,
we can refreeze it...
thank you.
Unlike any other
ice cream shop in the country.
(speaks indistinctly)
Wow, it's really hard.
For Lori, we have the chocolate
with Chocolate cookie dough.
For you I made coconut
with Berries, Kevin.
It tastes great.
So why go to this extreme
for ice cream?
(Naomi) first of all, it's more
creamy than regular ice cream.
The faster you freeze ice cream,
the creamier it is.
(daymond) Tastes like crap.
It's really good.
Really Good.
(mark) Mine's really good.
This tastes like crap.
Does it?
Mine's really good.
No, I'm just messing with you.
Ohh.
(laughter)
By removing
expensive freezer equipment,
we reduce the cost
of ownership for a store
and we reduce
the carbon footprint
of a frozen dessert shop.
We're not just
reinventing ice cream.
We're reinventing
the entire ice cream experience.
With your help, we can
blow away our competitors.
Who'd like to join us
and scream for our ice cream?
(laughs)
(whooshing)
Whoo!
Can you freeze Kevin?
(laughter)
Listen, before I get frozen,
I got a couple of questions.
And my biggest concern--
And by the way,
this is
very good ice cream.
Very creamy, different.
Presentation's very interesting.
If I have a line
of ten kids waiting...
right.
How fast can you process
each order?
Our average is about
30 seconds per person
from the time they order
to the time they're checked out
of the cash register.
My first job was
an ice cream scooper.
Been there, done that.
(laughs)
And what used to drive me crazy
was somebody saying,
"Can I have a taster?
No, no, I don't want the rest,
but--No, no, no.
I want the chocolate."
We don't have tasters,
'cause it's not made yet.
I can see Kevin as a little kid.
A kid--Another kid
keeps asking you for that
and you go,
"if I give you all the tasters,
I'm not gonna make any money."
(laughter)
is this a retail play?
That's right.
It is.
(Lori) Do you have
a number of outlets?
Yes.
(Jerry) We have
18 stores currently,
and we have about eight more
that have been sold.
Corporate or franchises?
2 corporate stores,
18 franchises.
Where are they located?
Washington,
Idaho, utah, arizona,
and california.
Jerry, is it perfectly safe,
the nitrogen?
Liquid nitrogen
is very, very cold.
I mean, it's 321 degrees
below zero.
It's what doctors use
to freeze off your warts.
No, it's the same stuff
they used to freeze Han solo.
Right?
(both) Yeah, exactly.
In fact, here...
oh!
There you go.
You're this far away.
That's--
There you go.
That's the image right there.
Yeah. Yeah.
What happens if I hire
an 18-year-old
and they freeze their hand off?
Well, we've developed processes
to make it safe.
We use nozzles
and we use systems
that are low pressure
so that they really
don't have the impact.
Okay, let's get
into the numbers,
because you're asking
for a lot.
$2.4 million value.
That's right.
Walk me through
the numbers.
So what were sales in 2011?
What do you think
they'll be this year?
2011, they were $2 million,
and this year we're projected
to be about $4 million
by the end of the year.
What's the capital cost to
set up a 600-Square-Foot unit?
A typical store
that's full-Blown
is between $125,000
and $175,000.
How much of your own money
is into this?
We've got about $750,000.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wow.
That's a lot of money.
We just took a loan--
Our first loan out
for $275,000.
If it costs about $125,000
to open a store...
Mm-hmm.
It's been seven years.
You've only opened up
two corporate stores.
Where did the $750,000 go?
Well, a lot of it was
developing this--
The systems and--
Did you lose a lot of money
along the way?
Um, a year and a half ago,
we--we partnered
with someone,
and the management decisions...
Well--
That he was making
was not right for the company.
And in order to, um,
to--to leave that situation,
we needed to buy him out.
For how much?
(Robert) Wow.
$500,000.
Ohh!
Whoa!
Whoa.
Things got very chilly
in here.
Why would you want to take on
another partner right now,
when you could grow this company
the way you've been doing it?
Well, there are some problems
that we've had
in our growth pattern
that I think that the sharks
Can help us with.
(Robert) such as?
Yeah, what are the problems?
(Jerry) Well, locations.
To get those "a" locations
and to get into stadiums,
you've got to have
some backing,
or else they're not gonna
really take you seriously.
You want us to strategically
help you
make a lot of calls and--
And help you with that, right?
I mean, it's, uh,
it's part of it.
So, guys, um,
I like the idea.
I-I just don't know
if I have the hours and the time
to give you the money
as well as Come
and help you work
with this project.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Unfortunately,
the ice cream operator business
is incredibly crowded.
I don't believe your business
right now is worth $2.4 million.
It's interesting.
Right.
But not enough for me
to invest. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
You lost $500,000
by hiring the wrong guy.
To me, you're trying
to do the same thing.
I--
at the same--
You're trying to bring in
people from the outside
and asking for $300,000.
At the same time,
I'm not sure--
And my guiding principle
is always
if it doesn't
make sense to me--
(Jerry) Well, uh--
Then it doesn't make sense.
Okay, well, let me--
For that reason,
Jerry, Naomi, I'm out.
Okay.
(Lori)
I think it's a great idea.
Right.
I think you two
are a great, strong,
willing-to-Do-
Whatever-it-takes team.
I think you can get there
on your own
and still own
your whole company.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Thanks.
Appreciate that. Thank you.
I like the idea. I think
you've got a lot of potential.
But I don't really want to be
in the ice cream
franchise business.
I will eat some more
of your ice cream, though,
But, um, I'm out.
Okay.
All right.
Well, I appreciate that.
Yes, we appreciate
your time.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Oh, well.
(sighs) Yeah.
We--Uh... we did okay.
(laughs)
We said everything
we wanted to say.
Yeah.
And more.
You know? There's not
anything that we left out,
and, yes, we tried.
♪♪♪
Next up are Beau Oyler
and Jared aller
with a product designed
for urban living.
Hello.
My name is Beau Oyler.
And I'm Jared aller.
And our company is urbio.
We're asking
for $300,000
for 12% of our company.
Inside of each of us is a need
to connect with nature
in a meaningful way,
and indoor plants are
a fantastic way of doing this.
People living in Large homes...
like all of you guys.
You've got plenty of space
for plants.
But for the rest of us
living in small spaces...
like Beau and myself...
and most people in the world,
we simply don't have
the room for indoor plants.
So Jared and I put our minds
together and created urbio,
the modern vertical garden.
Urbio is
a fully modular system,
so it can fit
on any wall.
And these little guys
have a magical twist--
Super-Strong magnets
that allow it to attach
to any metal surface,
including our metal wall plates,
which are super easy
to install.
(clicks)
Clickety-Clack,
and just like that,
you can have your own
urbio design for your lifestyle.
We've been absolutely
blown away
at the reception
urbio's received.
We've been featured
in multiple magazines,
blogs, and even tv shows.
And all of this
just in the last five months.
And the worldwide
response to urbio
has also been insane.
We've been sold
in over 50 different countries,
and the vertical garden is
just the tip of the iceberg.
We have infinite possibilities
for urbio
in every room in your home.
Yeah, such as kitchen,
bathroom, and office.
But the best part about urbio
is the experience.
Lori, come on down.
We'd like you to have
the experience
of placing an urbio magnetic pot
up on the wall.
There's a spot
right there for ya.
(clicks)
Whoa. It's strong.
I know, right?
Right.
How cool is that?
Very cool.
If there's one thing
that urbio knows how to do,
it's how to grow green.
So we're looking forward
to partnering with you
so that we can watch
urbio grow.
Thank you, Lori.
(mark) Hey, guys,
before you get started,
I get pitched all the time,
and these guys had
contacted me before
and--And solicited
an investment from me.
So I have to disqualify myself
because I know...
Yeah.
More about this investment
than the other sharks do,
which gives me
an unfair advantage, so...
I have to say I'm out,
but pitch away.
Yeah. We understand.
Wow.
You said you were blown away
by the response.
Why don't you blow me away
by your sales?
We have $125,000 in sales
in the first 4 months.
Where were you selling?
We've been selling in--
Through our web site.
We're in, uh,
about 25 different
brick-and-Mortar stores
right now.
Any big ones
that we would know,
or more mom-and-Pop?
We're working on that,
but we're--
Yeah.
But we have a large
distribution of mom-and-Pops.
Well, tell me a little bit
about it.
Like, what would that cost?
The urbio vessels
start at about $15
and go up to about $35.
To the customer?
to the customer.
That's full retail.
Does that include
the back plate?
And the back plates
are also $15.
And what about the smaller cups
that you have up there?
These ones here?
We call these the shorty.
Shorties. How much are they?
The shorties are 15 bucks.
And what does it cost you
to make each different piece?
So, the shorty
costs us $3.50,
so we have about
a 75% margin.
Is there anything out there
similar, though?
There is nothing on the market
that's like this.
There are lots
of vertical garden products,
but they have flaws in them.
They Leak a lot, and when
people try to water 'em
on the wall, they get moldy
and they stink.
How did you come up with it?
We're both trained
industrial designers.
We've designed products
that are now
in Williams-Sonoma,
best buy, target, costco.
We have a design studio
(Kevin) Yeah?
At which we design
for clients.
This here is our first
consumer product company
that we're launching.
You see, that's a bit of
a problem for me as an investor,
'cause I want you focused
on what I'm putting
my money into,
not some other clients.
Hmm.
How do I get you
to stop worrying
about those people and worrying
about this business full-time?
We have a great team--
Eight designers.
They're cranking out
work all the time,
which is a good thing,
because this is
an infinitely expandable,
uh, product line.
But what are you gonna do
with the $300,000 today?
We have orders pouring in.
Our inventory's flying out.
We need to order
more inventory.
So we need working capital.
We're not asking you
to pay our salaries.
We're asking you to help us
fill the next orders
and get more product
in our warehouse.
I'm gonna make you
an offer, okay?
I'll give you $300,000
for 20%,
but you can't take a salary
from this company.
You have to take a distribution
that all the shareholders get,
and you get to decide
when that is.
I want to put your shoes
in the same position I'm in.
Let me say this.
I love great design.
I love the purity of stuff that
is beautiful for what it is.
I'll make you an offer
with a bit of a twist.
Okay.
I'll give you $400,000
for the same 20%,
$300,000 for the equity,
and $100,000 to go out
and hire a guy
to run this full-time.
I think you need somebody
to come in
and quarterback
all the activity and flurry
that's going on with you.
You guys can be the brains
behind it,
but you need somebody there
every day, 24 by 7.
Yeah.
That's my offer.
(daymond)
I'll tell you what, guys.
I think the--I think
the other two offers
are pretty generous.
I just can't understand
that valuation.
And maybe I'm just a greedy
Savage, 'cause I would ask...
(chuckling)
Way more than what the other
sharks are offering right now.
So...
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks, daymond.
Do you have any type of
intellectual property on it?
Do you have a patent?
We have a design
and utility patent pending.
Are you willing to work to
reduce the cost of the product?
Yes.
Okay.
The magnets are a significant
portion of our cost.
So I took a plane to China,
and I found an awesome,
um, magnet manufacturer.
That's in the pipeline
right now,
and we're reducing our cost.
Okay. I'll make you an offer.
$300,000 for 20%.
And I think you know
that through qvc, drtv,
and brick-and-Mortar
retail stores and Online,
we will blow this out there
fast and furious,
because that is
what I am best at.
You know what I find
interesting?
You never talked about
the beauty of the design.
We will. I love it.
You never talked about
the design.
They know I love it.
Can't you tell I love it?
Yeah.
You guys are cool and hip
and so is your product,
and that's the focus
of this market.
Oh, my god.
People that are in small spaces
just starting out
that want something
really hip.
People that are watching qvc
are grandmothers.
Oh, my god.
Face it--
Sometimes you remind me
of a golf ball--
Small, bald, and I want to
hit you 300 feet away from me.
The point is,
am I wrong?
(laughter)
(Robert) That was good.
Lori, that was the best line
you've had so far.
That was really Good.
Guys, we have three offers.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
but Beau and Jared have
three offers on the table.
Guys, we have three offers.
You have, uh, $300,000
for 20% by Mr. O'Leary.
You have $400,000 for 20%
by Robert,
with $100,000 going to
have somebody to head it up,
and then you have $300,000
for 20% by Lori.
What are you gonna do?
I know I've gotten
products out there
literally within months.
I can sell hundreds of thousands
of dollars in minutes,
but also I have connections
to all of the retailers
across the country
and internationally.
Jared, do you know what I hear?
And I might have better
sourcing for you...
Jared--
Because I also have
factories and manufacturers
that I use all over the world.
Jared, you know what I hear?
I hear--
It is all one-Stop--
I hear, "me, me, me, me."
This is your design.
He's not hearing,
"me, me, me, me."
(daymond) Shark fight!
Shark fight!
This is your design.
It's not a partnership.
This is what I always do.
Shark fight! Shark fight!
Thank you for your offers.
These are all great offers,
and as we look
at all the sharks,
you guys would be
fantastic partners,
each of you
for your different aspects.
So let me sweeten the deal
a little bit more.
(laughs)
This is a purchase order
from the container store.
18,000 units
just for the first order--
Nationwide, every store,
committed end cap
in every single store.
What's the dollar amount?
$150,000.
Here's the thing.
I'm gonna go down to 15%...
ooh.
If you say yes to me right now.
(Richard) guys, I offered you
$400,000 for 20%.
I'll split it with you.
I'll do $400,000 at 17.5%.
(Kevin) I'm gonna leave
my offer alone.
I think I bring
a unique skill to this.
Anybody can get on
direct selling television.
Oh, that is so not True.
It's so True.
I think I bring
a lot of value
that I want reflected.
I'm gonna stand firm.
Yeah.
So, guys, you have--
You have
three firm offers.
Yes.
So what are you gonna do?
(whispers) Lori?
(whispers) Yeah.
(normal voice)
We're gonna keep our equity.
Lori, we'd like to accept
your offer.
Will you be
our business partner?
Great. Yes.
Love to.
(laughter)
It's great.
Thank you.
Awesome.
We're gonna do
great things.
We're so excited.
Me, too. Me, too.
Thank you, Lori.
Thank you very much.
Awesome. Thank you so much.
(mark) Congrats, guys.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Appreciate it.
Good luck to you.
Great to be with you.
I feel like throwing this
at you.
(laughter)
Sorry.
Sorry, Robert.
Thank you. Thanks.
(daymond) Lori...
wow.
You stood firm,
you called Kevin a golf ball,
and you made a profit.
That was the best part
of the whole bit.
You won't be coming golfing
with me.
(laughs)